so I think one aspect of the divide
between conservative giving giving and
liberal giving is that liberals think of
it as a government responsibility to
redistribute wealth and guarantee social
justice whereas conservatives see it as
an individual obligation to give back to
the community thus you represent a kind
of interesting hybrid between personal
work and advocating for government to
change things so if the LGBT community
hopefully when secures their their
federal rights that are the same as
straight individuals what do you think
is your personal obligation in terms of
philanthropy well I think the I were I
don't know that I'd argue with you
necessarily on the broader philosophical
truth what you said but on the ground
with these civil rights movements it
ends up practically being very different
because the civil rights movement
learned and the women's rights movement
following them and the LGBT movement
learned the government isn't giving you
anything we none of these moot not only
did these movements not wait for the
government to redistribute wealth or
take care of Social Services the
government is the enemy the government
is who we were fighting we're fighting
the laws and we're fighting the courts
and that and so the I think for the sort
of that general liberal group which is
who I was talking about before who are
the ones that we're all trying to reach
and get on our side maybe yes but when
when you're within a civil rights
movement fighting for your rights you've
got to be proactive and the government
is who you're fighting the government is
is the government is who you're
demanding the rights from the
conservative movement becomes your
adversaries because they're trying to
prevent you from getting those rights
but at the end of the day they're really
not they're not your they're not
physically who you have to deal with who
you're what you're trying to deal with
is the government and changing laws
would you want this Bruce will you
respond to this part of Connor's
question in this you've had successes
this is this CNN poll proves that
there's been yeah
another success in changing the hearts
and minds of a majority when you achieve
the ultimate success will your activism
continue and will and do you believe all
of those folks who are now energized in
the LGBT movement will they continue to
be active in some other area or or is it
just this modus movement well okay the
struggle is never over I mean you're not
surely we're not going to make a case at
the African American civil rights
movement is over or that women's rights
is over I mean with the ER a has never
passed the women technically don't have
equal rights in this country to this day
and you look at all the statistics of
salaries and you know title line in
sports and nothing's equal nothing's
even close to being equal so it would be
a nice idea but the struggle is never
over but we were talking earlier about
you know the Far international issues
versus American issues and the question
of life how would you balance your time
between them the when you're starting
out as a philanthropist and wanting to
have a life long association with social
activism which I hope to goodness all of
you will because that you obviously
you're interested in the subject and now
you want to put it into practice you at
the beginning you you might and you
probably should have that moment where
you get to decide what causes you're
involved in and that should be a very
personal and very passionate choice of
where you're going to try and affect
change in in in America in around the
world for a certain group of people for
candidates what are your issues the good
news and the bad news is if you're at
all successful in that space if you
start doing good work if you're able to
either come up with great ideas or put
them into action or raise some money or
write some checks the incoming needs and
requests for your everything for your
talent for your money what's this class
for your time talent treasure time
talent and treasure is
so enormous because the world isn't
needs so much help and people need so
much help and there's so much to be done
that you actually quickly and it's a
good thing because it means you're doing
the right work you you will lose the
balance shifts it's really not it's not
up to you anymore as 20 I'm going to go
out and do this it's much more incoming
you know you you have I certainly have I
have more requests for my help in all
these different areas on any given week
or month then I can possibly do so it
becomes just a choice of you know you've
got but that's kind of how you know
you're in the struggle and it's kind of
how you know that'll never end and it's
kind of how you know that somewhat work
to do is you look at all of the groups
and all of the people at all the events
that need your help and you gotta
prioritize you know you don't want to
overextend yourself because if you're
not coming through four people then
you're not helping anyone and so it's
figuring out you know okay I'll focus on
this case today and you know the gay
rights crisis that's happening in Africa
that this other organization needs my
help on there they're gonna have to wait
right now oh but Human Rights Watch
wants me to get involved in the Southern
California committee and I could kind of
tilt two birds with one stone because
I've just learned that they're actually
doing great work in Africa so if I join
that committee and help them with their
dinner and bring a little Hollywood
judge to some of the stuff that they're
doing then I I can actually feel less
horrified about having to say no to the
group that contacted me directly just
because I have too much on my plate so
it's you know and but I think it's all a
positive thing is it becomes you know
it's like triage it's more just a matter
of 16 candidates in 20 in 12 different
states all wat be to have events for
them and raise money for that bad
campaign for them and the elections role
in november and i only have one group of
people that i go to that i asked for
money so I know I can't do 16 how many
can I do and who are those people and
let me try and jump in and help the ones
I can and I'm just not going to be able
to to do it all
do everything obviously I mean there's
just way too much to be done